are nfts a scam or are they the next big
thing legally speaking it's a question
between uber and theranos uber was able
to sidestep regulation to become a
billion dollar company and basically is
interwoven into the fabric of society
whereas theranose tried to fake it until
they made it but they ran up against
physics and biology and were just a
giant fraud
nfts are probably somewhere in the
middle they're certainly not unicorns
that are going to solve all problems but
they're probably not all completely
useless and either way they raise
fundamental issues of law so today we're
going to cover only the legal problems
associated with nfts others have
explained the non-legal issues for
example dan olsen at folding ideas did a
fantastic video called the line goes up
which is not to say that the technology
can't overcome these problems but right
now there are some fundamental issues of
law with the way that nfts are used now
and i see three main categories of
issues with nfts on-chain problems
off-chain problems and what i call
innovation so mundane no one should care
now to get to those issues with nfts we
first have to define what an nft is
because i think almost everyone gets it
wrong an nft is a non-fungible token it
is an entry on a decentralized ledger
called a blockchain a blockchain is a
permanent unchangeable digital ledger
that's used to record transactions in
blocks of computer code that are time
stamped and linked together the code
will reveal the history of a digital
asset where it originated who purchased
it and any subsequent transfers and in
the digital world the token can be
assigned specific uses and properties
now it's non-functional because it is
said to be unique unlike something like
bitcoin where every single bitcoin is
interchangeable with another one it's
like a dollar bill every dollar bill
that you possess effectively does the
exact same thing as another dollar bill
same with a bitcoin however an nft is
said to be unique so they are not
fungible with each other but at this
point let me turn it over to someone
more technically minded my friend steve
mold to explain how an nft actually
operates because it's illuminating so
steve how does an nft work nfts work in
a very similar way to bitcoins we track
who owns what bitcoin on a distributed
ledger as you mentioned in the case of
bitcoin that distributed ledger is
called the bitcoin blockchain but nfts
exist on a different blockchain
typically the ethereum blockchain the
difference between bitcoin and ethereum
is that the ethereum blockchain is
programmable you can write programs and
publish them to the ethereum blockchain
these aren't programs that you would run
on your computer these programs run on
the blockchain and they interact with
transactions on the blockchain for
example
you could write a program and publish it
to the ethereum blockchain that launches
a new cryptocurrency to rival bitcoin
but it's not just limited to
cryptocurrency you could use the
ethereum programming language to do all
sorts of things including for example
making nfts these programs are called
smart contracts which is misleading
because look here's an example of a
smart contract there's no legal language
in there it doesn't function as a legal
document though i can see why they
wanted to call them smart contracts
because they enforce transactional rules
on the blockchain just like normal
software once you publish a smart
contract to the blockchain you can
interact with it by sending it commands
for example you could send a command
telling it to mint a new nfd or you
could send a command to change the owner
of an nft smart contracts can be used
for much more than just cryptocurrency
and nfds for example you could write a
smart contract that acts as an escrow
between people buying and selling nfts
the definition of an nft is quite strict
by consensus we've agreed that if a
smart contract behaves in certain
specific ways as defined by a standard
called erc721
and one other then we call that an nft
smart contract so how does all this
relate to digital art well let's have a
look at the most expensive board ape
ever sold that's board ape number two
zero eight seven let's head over to
etherscan a website for exploring the
ethereum blockchain this is the address
of the smart contract that mints board
ape nfts
erc721 contracts can be queried in
certain ways for example i can use the
owner of query to find out who owns a
particular nft so board ape 2087 is
owned by this person the erc721 standard
also includes something called the token
uri if i put 2087 in here i get this
this is a uri on the public internet for
anyone to see it's an ipfs address so
let's head over to the brave browser and
see where that takes us this is some
machine readable json code but let's
make it a bit easier to read for humans
and look you can see that's the uri for
the ape image itself and here are some
attributes of the ape for example its
mouth is bored cigarette the background
is purple the fur is trippy the eyes are
angry
let's grab this image uri and stick it
back into the brave browser and there it
is so when you buy an nft that's linked
to a digital artwork you're buying a
unique location on the ethereum
blockchain that points to a text file on
the internet
for everyone to see inside that text
file is another uri that points to the
image itself again on the internet for
everyone to see believe me there are a
bunch of weird technical details that
need to be talked about associated with
nfts i cover all of that over on my
channel but the bottom line is when you
buy crypto art you're buying a line in a
tamper-proof ledger that points to a
publicly hosted image file
so at the end of the day to summarize i
think the best analogy for an nft is not
digital property as a lot of people like
to claim i think the best analogy for
what an nft actually is is a receipt it
is a receipt of some transaction a buyer
and seller interacted in some way and an
nft is a receipt of that transaction
that receipt often links to something
off-chain often that is a jpeg but the
receipt itself doesn't really tell you
what the transaction was to know what
happened in that transaction you have to
look at the terms of the original sale
the contract you also have to look at
the reference work often that's a jpeg
but the nft itself is simply a entry in
a digital ledger that's kind of like a
receipt in the real world okay so with
that understanding i think we can get to
the first category of legal problems
associated with nfts which are the
problems that are inherent on chain and
for that i'm afraid we're going to have
to talk about the fundamental contract
theory honestly i didn't think that this
video was going to require me to get
back to first principles of contract law
the kind of thing that you learned in
your first year of law school and yet
here we are and we need to understand
how a contract works how it binds the
parties and what the limitations of
contracts are and i know that sounds
super boring but i'm going to explain
that with wrestler and renaissance man
john cena because in 2017 john cena
contracted with the ford motor company
to buy the new ford gt the new hottest
sports car at the time in order for him
to buy that car he formed a contract
with ford he offered to pay them
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
ford offered to give him
a ford gt but in particular there was
one term that ford included in the sales
contract john cena had to agree not to
sell his ford gt for two years and that
has a perfectly enforceable sale
contract ford doesn't have to sell that
to anyone and so to make sure that john
cena didn't turn around flip the car for
hundreds of thousands of dollars they
made him promise not to sell the car for
two years what did john cena do he
turned around and flipped the car almost
immediately and made hundreds of
thousands of dollars so
what could ford motor company do ford
could sue john cena for hundreds of
thousands of dollars and in fact they
did sue him and they settled for an
undisclosed amount but the really
interesting question is what can ford do
against the person that bought the car
from john cena and the answer is
absolutely nothing because there's no
contract between ford and the person
that bought the car from john cena
the secondary buyer is said to not be in
privity with ford john cena and ford are
in privity they have an actual contract
but there's nothing linking forward in
the downstream purchaser so what in the
world does this have to do with nfts
well here's the thing we talked about
how an nft doesn't really have any
attributes in and of itself when you're
buying an nft the real thing that you're
buying is bound by the contract between
the buyer and the seller those are the
primary purchaser and seller there are
some times when there is no contract
we'll talk about that but theoretically
at least the value of the nft is decided
by the contract terms between the buyer
and the seller of the nft but one of the
huge fundamental problems that we'll
talk about a lot in a second is that in
practice there's rarely any contract
between the initial primary buyer and
the secondary buyers and then all of the
downstream buyers later on and on top of
that there is zero contractual privity
between secondary buyers and the
original issuer of the nft that's a real
problem when the only value associated
with an nft comes from the initial sale
terms so let's talk about an example of
this in practice many people are
familiar with nba top shots which was
designed by dapper labs nba top shots is
an nba platform that purports to allow
you to own moments that happen in the
nba often small snippets of videos
related to nba plays now when you buy in
nba top shot nft the transactions are
registered on the flow blockchain which
was basically created out of whole cloth
by dapper labs to facilitate the
transactions of nba top shots when you
initially buy an nba top shot you get
limited rights to use and view the nba
top shot only within the nba top shots
platform but here's the thing nba top
shots is a private marketplace the nfts
only have any real value when you use
the walled garden of nba top shots you
have to use their app or their website
for the nft to have any functionality at
all but in a way it works because
everyone is on the same platform
effectively nba top shots is simply a
normal web 2.0 website where you're
allowed to buy and sell things only
within their specific platform and the
terms of sale travel with the particular
nfts because everyone is buying into the
same system if you somehow got an nba
top shot nft and was able to sell it on
a different blockchain well odds are the
terms and conditions don't flow and you
have an nft that has zero value at all
because it won't even work with the
original nba top shots platform so if
you're not nba top shots and you're not
forcing everyone to use the same walled
garden how do you bind secondary
purchasers how do you even know what
you're buying when you're buying an nft
well that is incredibly controversial
now another famous example is the board
ape yacht club that is famous for
selling nfts of monkey cartoons now you
can buy a board ape nft on openc which
is a large marketplace for nfts when you
do the board ape yacht club says that
you get access to certain perks these
include getting access to their discord
server of like-minded purchasers of
board apes but for the most part those
are perks that are offered off chain and
by the originator of the nfts
board could change their mind because
it's questionable whether the terms and
conditions travel with the downstream
purchasers of every single board ape if
those terms and conditions legally fail
say board ape says they're not in
privity with all of those downstream
purchasers and then they decide to cut
off access to maybe some bad actors who
were spamming the the board ape discord
well then those purchasers who spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars may
have zero recourse because if they're
not in contractual privity there's
nothing that binds board ape to provide
those things long term they may in fact
provide those things but they might not
legally be required to now if you're a
normal website you'd probably provide
what's called a click wrap agreement
that's one of those contracts that you
kind of scroll through and then click i
agree well that provides a whole bunch
of terms and conditions sometimes those
bind the users sometimes that binds the
platform itself now when it comes to
nfts you could provide a click wrap
agreement i don't see that being done
very much but there's a fundamental
problem the agreement isn't necessarily
linked to the nft itself you could also
theoretically put the terms of sale in
the reference work that's held off chain
but again that is something that is not
necessarily connected to the nft itself
it can change over time and you still
have no guarantee that the buyer has
read the terms when the sale is
consummated and as you have more and
more secondary purchasers and you get
further and further away from the
initial sale the problems just get
harder and harder to make sure that all
of the downstream purchasers
saw an assented to all of the contract
terms and to make sure that the prior
sellers and the original mentor are
bound by the same terms to provide the
thing that was originally provided when
the nft was minted and the fundamental
question if you buy an nft that doesn't
have any sale terms whatsoever
what have you purchased
the answer is probably nothing at least
nothing that the law can protect we'll
talk about this later but one of the off
chain problems with nfts is that the
reference work can change you can get
rug pulled
and if you don't have a contract that
says you are entitled to one specific
thing well the nft doesn't tell you what
the thing was that you were supposed to
buy in a way an nft is like a hyperlink
and you can't own a hyperlink so if you
buy an nft that doesn't have contract
terms it doesn't define what you have
purchased and you aren't familiar with
the terms of conditions and you want to
try and enforce that nft against someone
that you purchased it from i'm afraid to
tell you that i think you own about as
much as a hyperlink which is to say you
can't own that many people claim that
nfts supplant copyright law entirely and
unfortunately that's not even close nfts
are a product of contract law extremely
fundamental ideas of contract law and
there are real problems when it comes to
enforcing those contracts and creating
privity between the original mentor and
downstream purchasers now one of the
things that nfts can do is that they can
be attributed with some basic
programming so-called smart contracts
now and these smart contracts are
basically contracts in the same sense
that a microchip is a contract it's it's
not a legally binding document it just
has a bit of programming to do things
when certain conditions are met and
these smart contracts seem to do well
when they are based on internet native
occurrences and simple transactions the
kind of thing like an escrow account
where you don't release funds until
certain conditions precedent are met but
these smart contracts these tiny
programs are not real contracts they
don't bind the downstream purchasers and
in fact
as we've seen they can break over time
there are no legal rights that are
created as a result of the smart
contracts themselves so for better or
worse lawyers exist for a reason and
programmers are really really bad at
planning for contingencies and they're
also really bad at understanding
contract law in general
so the bottom line is that nfts are a
product of contract the terms under
which you bought them so for all of
those who purchased in nfts i'm sure
that you all checked the terms and
conditions before you purchased right
you got terms and conditions right
and that brings us to copyright because
nfts do not supplant copyright law not
even close nfts are bound by normal
everyday rules of copyright when you buy
an nft sometimes you get the copyright
but most of the times you don't again it
entirely depends on the original terms
of sale related to the nft
nba top shots for example does not give
you a copyright in the original video to
the nba they give you an extremely
limited license to use that video in
extremely limited places and nothing
more some other famous examples where
people think they're buying the
copyright but aren't include cryptos and
board ape yacht club with cryptos they
basically operate under the creative
commons zero license where if you buy a
cryptos jpeg they allow you to do
basically whatever you want with them
but again cryptos hangs on to the
original copyright they simply license
it to downstream purchasers same thing
with the board ape yacht club
they offer a fairly expansive license
but again they hold the ips centrally
and you're just simply given a license
you are not buying the copyright
associated with the board ape
cartoon that you purchased and with
board ape the license is held off-chain
which means that that license might
change over time and you might never
even know about it and often this has
very little to do with copyright at all
if you buy an nba top shot let's say of
a particular clip of something that
happened in the nba
you can't enforce that against someone
who is displaying that piece of video
somewhere else
and on top of that the nba can prevent
you from displaying that particular
video clip if you're displaying it in a
way that conflicts with the license that
was purchased through nba top shots
which again is incredibly restrictive
and the issue of copyright is incredibly
important because when you're talking
about digital art that's often the only
right that the law recognizes if you
don't have the copyright then you
effectively have nothing and that's
important because in the context of nfts
a lot of the art that is being bought
and sold
probably doesn't have a copyright at all
it's uncopyrightable the ultimate irony
is that when it comes to digital art
that does have a copyright ironically
the copyright is a scarce resource
there's only one sure you can license it
an infinite number of times
or you can assign the copyright
but
the copyright itself is inherently
scarce
and maybe we never needed to solve the
digital scarcity question at all because
it was already solved through regular
copyright law because a lot of the
reference art that's associated with the
nft is called generative art it's art
that's created by ai or programmatically
through a computer you might have heard
of the ninth circuit case naruto versus
slater that is the monkey selfie case
where the courts recognize that only a
human can create art that has a
copyright in that particular case there
was a monkey that got a hold of a
photographer's camera took a selfie and
the photographer tried to exercise a
copyright in that particular piece of
artwork at the same time peta said that
the the monkey owned the copyright to
that particular photo and they
intervened to try to exercise the
monkeys rights on its behalf and the
court found that no one had a copyright
because only humans can have a copyright
in art only humans can create art that
is copyrightable so by extension if a
machine is deemed to be the author of a
work no one can exercise a copyright in
that particular artwork and in the
context of nfts there's untold numbers
of works that are touted as being
created by computers that's deemed to be
a feature not a bug and if that's the
case i don't think that there is a
copyright there to begin with no one can
exercise any rights associated with that
uh artwork because
no human created it even with the very
famous bordeape yacht club it seems to
be just a rehashing of the same elements
over and over and over again which i
believe were hashed by a computer rather
than a person a person may have created
the individual elements once upon a time
but the individual artworks were created
by a computer now there are some
complicated issues related to copyrights
of compilations and works for hire but
there is an argument that some very very
expensive nfts
simply don't have a copyright at all
now in fairness to nfts in the real
world when you buy real art you buy a
physical painting
it's normal not to buy the copyright
associated with that particular painting
when you buy a novel you are not buying
the copyright associated with that novel
so it's not unusual in the art world to
not get the copyright associated with a
work and so in some sense it's normal
not to get a copyright associated with
digital art the issue here is that
digital art doesn't have a physical
token
if you aren't getting the copyright
associated with the digital art you're
not really getting anything that is
protectable under the law but of course
in the real world you actually have a
physical thing and that's associated
with a legal doctrine called the first
sale doctrine that when you buy a
physical good whether it is a painting
or a pair of nike shoes you can
basically do whatever you want to that
physical good you don't have necessarily
the right to reproduce or otherwise use
an image of the thing that you have
purchased but you do have the right to
basically do whatever you want with the
physical good itself including selling
it to somebody else physical works of
art are almost inherently scarce as well
a painting
can only be painted by a human once and
nfts are touted as solving the infinite
reproducibility problem with digital
works where legally speaking at least no
nft can claim to have providence over an
artwork that is itself legally
infinitely reproducible so when it comes
to digital art such as jpegs if you're
not buying the copyright i'm not sure
legally what you are buying and as a
non-legal aside i know art is inherently
subjective and there's no objectivity in
art and claiming that something is good
art or bad art is inherently in coheit
but i mean just look at this stuff this
is bad art and if you're claiming that
this art is inherently worth hundreds of
thousands of dollars apart from any
speculative value
i don't think you're good at art so that
takes us to consumer protection issues
we've seen that there is a vast gulf
between what people think they are
getting and what they're actually
getting when it comes to nfts
and these nfts are widely promoted by a
wide variety of different people
including the the people that are
selling these things and people who are
paid to promote them and it doesn't seem
that anyone really knows exactly what
they are receiving platforms like nba
top shots who you can assume have
legions of lawyers have actually changed
a lot of the marketing language that
they've used
historically they used language like
owning a moment but that probably
doesn't line up with the idea of getting
an extremely limited ip license to view
and display the reference work almost
exclusively on the top shots platform
now they use language like scoring in
nft or collecting in nft which to me is
very very different than the idea of
owning a moment and it almost goes
without saying but i'll say it anyway
you can't own a moment that is not a
thing that the law recognizes that
anyone can own you might as well try and
buy
a star in a faraway galaxy you can't own
that and it seems like there is a huge
amount of misperception
in terms of what people think they're
getting in terms of ownership and of
course the false promises from the
mentors are compounding that effect and
whenever you have false promises from
sellers and misperceptions of buyers you
run into consumer protection issues if i
was a mentor or a seller of nfts i'd
make darn sure that every single person
saw the terms and conditions so that
there was no confusion as to what i was
selling and what they were buying but
that's just simply not happening in this
industry
and while many people would probably try
and claim first amendment protection
the first amendment does not extend
nearly as much to buyers and sellers of
goods when you have commercial sales and
commercial speech the first amendment
doesn't protect nearly as much as you'd
think it would and as we discussed many
nfts drop without any terms whatsoever
and for those that do have terms it's
not at all clear that those terms travel
with downstream purchasers of those nfts
nfts are also a product of programming
and as we've seen time and time again
those programs can fail an nft can be
corrupted the reference work can be rug
pulled you can change the the reference
work even if you're pointing to an ipfs
file
that can change
who's responsible if the nft isn't even
delivering the things that it was
supposed to deliver if those terms exist
often nfts provide the division of
royalties and revenue streams but those
often only work if the blockchain is
working you better hope that the
blockchain doesn't fork that the
programming works and that it provides
for every single contingency that you
can think of because those things break
all the time and there are all kinds of
laws that make sure that consumers are
protected by contracts of adhesion there
is the e-sign act that governs whether a
click-wrap agreement on a website is
enforceable
both against the seller and to the buyer
these are effectively the same kinds of
issues that any kind of e-commerce
website is going to have to deal with
but effectively every single individual
buyer and seller of an nft have to deal
with the same thing and
many people just aren't making sure that
contract terms are enforceable is a
known issue that all websites whether
it's web 2.0 or web 3 have to deal with
and you might try and put a contract on
openc if that is the marketplace that
you are trying to sell your nft but
right now there's no guarantee that
anyone's going to read it and if no
one's reading the contract terms you've
got big issues in terms of
enforceability let alone privity and the
bottom line is that you have to make
sure that consumers are affirmatively
consenting
to the contract terms and if you can't
prove that that might be your problem
but it also might be the problem of the
nft purchasers if they want to make sure
that third parties are providing
off-chain
unlocked goods
well you'd better have a contract that
makes sure that they actually provide
those things
and then there's all kinds of securities
related legal issues nfcs are being
marketed mostly as art or collectibles
but at the same time there is so much
hype and so much speculation
people tout them as incredible
investment opportunities premised on the
idea that they will always increase in
value at the moment it's incredibly
unclear but it's possible that the
securities exchange commission the sec
could classify certain nfts as security
if they are classified as securities
this triggers all kinds of regulatory
issues with potential liabilities and
while it's currently unclear courts will
use what's called the howie test to
determine whether these things are
securities or not that stems from a
supreme court case under this test a
transaction is deemed an investment
contract if a person quote invests his
money in a common enterprise and is led
to expect profits solely from the
efforts of the promoter or a third party
this was a huge problem for the ico the
initial coin offering boom of 2017
because those initial coin offerings ran
afoul of the howie test and were
regulated as securities effectively
people offered
coins on a blockchain related to some
enterprise for a thing that had not yet
been created and as a result you rarely
see initial coin offerings anymore at
least not from companies that are trying
to abide by the law but now the argument
against nft's securities is that nfts
are finished products not investment
vehicles that need to be managed if nfts
appreciate in value it's through
principles like scarcity and just market
forces not because of a third party's
effort to enhance the nft's value and
the sec's 2019 framework says quote
price appreciation resulting solely from
external market forces such as general
inflationary trends or the economy
impacting the supply and demand of an
underlying asset generally is not
considered profit under the howey test
so an increase in value alone doesn't
make something a security however some
of the proposed uses of nfts are a much
closer call and would probably be
considered securities if push came to
shove things like royalty payments to
artists especially if the art hasn't
been created yet would be a much closer
call
and even apart from securities related
regulation
there seems to be all kinds of just
garden variety fraud the nft markets are
rife with rug pulls and rick rolls
people who are intentionally scamming
other people out of hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars not
in the sense that nfts in general are a
scam but literally these things are
actual scams where they're
making false promises knowing that they
are false and then not providing on the
thing that they promise to provide i
mean that is just good old-fashioned
fraud but don't take my word for it i
turn to the foremost expert in crypto
related scams coffeezilla to give me a
recent salient example
one example of what an nft project
promised and then didn't deliver on what
it said it would was de aaron fox's
project called swipe of the fox deering
is an nba player for the sacramento
kings and he recently pulled in 1.5
million dollars in nft sales in part due
to a road map where he had promised some
pretty extraordinary things which would
give these nfts some real world utility
for example one of the perks was going
to be a metaverse basketball court five
scholarships charity giveaways free
merch even tickets to all-star games
these all gave investors the impression
that these nfts might have real world
value and be worth buying however right
after the money came in deer and fox
issued a statement saying he was too
busy with his mba career to make all
that happen and was quitting the project
no refunds of course
apparently he wasn't too busy to start
the nft just too busy to deliver on what
he promised
then of course there's all kinds of
market manipulations many of the high
dollar amount transactions related to
very high ticket nfts are not conducted
by arm's length transactions they might
be wash sales where an individual sells
an nft to themselves using a sock puppet
or there might be coordination between
two different people who agree to
pay a high price for something to prop
up the price
because the blockchain is
quasi-anonymous pseudonymous if you want
to get technical it's very easy for
people to create sock puppet accounts
that they control so that they can show
a price history of their nft being sold
for lots and lots of money so that some
unsuspecting downstream purchaser thinks
well if that person paid this much then
i'll pay even more and i'll be able to
sell it to somebody else down the line
for even more than that now this to me
raises garden variety issues of fraud
it's just out and out fraud and market
manipulation
it could even be a violation of the
sherman antitrust act this is the kind
of anti-competitive behavior
that the doj and ftc likes to crack down
on and often when you get into price
manipulation among several different
people well then you're getting into
criminal liability under the the sherman
act maybe there's an infinite supply of
greater fools when the prices keep going
up but as soon as any particular nft
crashes and a buyer realizes that there
was price manipulation before they
purchased their nft they might come
looking for some heads to roll and there
might be some real civil and criminal
liability associated with people who
were propping up the prices unfairly and
then there's lots of just pump and dump
schemes people who maybe aren't
promoting an out and out scam but are
looking to make a quick buck and there's
right now a proposed class action
against people who promoted ethereum max
people like kim kardashian floyd
mayweather paul pierce
they promoted this token on their social
media chains
and right now there's a class action
because it was clearly a pump and dump
scheme and the ethereum max lawsuit
doesn't rely on federal securities law
it relies on pretty normal state-based
causes of action like unjust enrichment
violations of california's unfair
competition law and the california
consumer legal remedies act
i don't know that we will ever know for
certain how many nfts are sold in wash
sales
how many people are trying to drive up
the price of these things but anyone who
is manipulating the market here
really faces some truly terrifying civil
liability
and maybe jail time and those are just
the on-chain problems that takes us to
the off-chain problems associated with
nfts the first of which is you need to
make sure that if you're selling an nft
you have the rights to the reference
work recently an nft mentor called hit
piece purported to issue an nft related
to every song on spotify's database so
they would effectively take the album
artwork and mint and nft related to the
artist and name of the song
it seems like that raises some very
truly terrifying issues in terms of hit
piece not owning any of the rights
associated with any of the songs artists
or
album artwork associated with the nfts
that they claim to be making now
interestingly there is a novel issue of
copyright here since the nft doesn't
contain the musical work itself there's
an open question whether these nfts
violate the musical copyright i'd argue
they probably do but that's a separate
issue and on top of that there is no
question that minting an nft related to
a band and their song using all of those
names and their album work certainly
violate the trademark related to this
particular band and song and probably a
myriad of other attribution-related
legal issues as well then there was
another music-related nft project called
streamer.fm that claimed that because
you could stream music on spotify and
youtube
they were somehow allowed to mint these
nfts and restream the music which is not
how any of this works at all
fundamentally here clearing the rights
and making sure you have the rights to
mint the nft in the first place goes
back to old-fashioned boring concepts of
contract and copyright law nft and
blockchain technology not only doesn't
supplant or replace
those bedrock principles of law they
often run headlong right into it and
when it comes to
this corpus of law and brand new nfts
nfts are going to lose
but there's all kinds of minting nfts
without permission and often you have no
way of knowing whether the original
mentor had the rights and the clearances
to mint the nfts that they are minting
proponents of nfts claim that nfts can
prove digital provenance related to
works of art but the truth is often you
have no idea if the original mentor has
any of the rights associated with the
work in the first place and
there's absolutely no way to know except
through conducting an investigation
completely off chain this is actually
one of the issues associated with the
quentin tarantino and miramax case in
that case quentin tarantino the director
was trying to mint some nfts related to
the film pulp fiction and it's a
complete morass to try and figure this
out because tarantino retains some
rights to the screenplay of the movie
pulp fiction but miramax retains almost
all of the rights associated with the
movie itself and it's going to take a
lot of litigation to figure out who owns
what rights and who has the right to
make nfts related to either the
screenplay or the movie itself and good
luck if you think the nfc itself is
going to prove the answer to either of
those questions then of course there's
all kinds of good old-fashioned
regulatory risk a lot of people have
explained that an nft or a blockchain
might make perfect sense in the context
of say real estate title where having a
public decentralized blockchain of who
buys and sells houses
could
actually be much better than the current
system of a centralized title system but
good luck trying to convince a state or
municipality to adopt that and if your
blockchain runs into something that's
already highly regulated like real
estate title you can't wave a magic wand
and force the government to adopt your
technical solution even if your
technical solution has
some benefits over the universally
adopted system one of the biggest issues
is as a downstream purchaser how do you
make sure that you can enforce all of
the terms against the previous
purchasers and the original nft minter
but the problem also goes the other way
as well if those terms do travel down
that chain
let's say that you are a band or a
youtube creator and as part of your nft
you issue some sort of unlockable
content like
a meet and greet with the band and based
on the terms of sale anyone who ever
purchases that particular nft has the
right to enforce a meet and greet
against the band well as the seller are
you prepared to offer a meet and greet
with every single person who ever
purchases that nft down the line because
depending on the terms of the sale you
might be obligated to provide that
otherwise you might get hit with things
like breach of contract or fraud
depending on the value of the thing that
you have promised to provide i was
talking to a very large youtube creator
who wanted to create an nft i'm not
going to name him but i am going to wish
him congratulations when he passes 100
billion subscribers in just a little
while and he wanted to offer a video
conference with whoever purchased this
nft
24 hours a day 365 days out of the year
and i suggested to him that maybe that
wasn't a good idea unless he'd liked
being woken up in the middle of the
night and being forced to provide a
video conference with every single
person who purchased his nft and lo and
behold he didn't go through with it i
think that was a smart thing i've seen
lots of people claim that there is
absolutely no downside to creators
creating their own nfts
on the contrary there's all kinds of
potential pitfalls if you're not smart
about these things then there's things
like product liabilities nfts break all
the time who's responsible if the link
between the nft and the reference
material breaks who's responsible if the
blockchain forks and your revenue stream
is then cut off these are sort of
bedrock ideas of product liability
on top of which it's not at all clear
from the blockchain itself that the
thing isn't functioning you've got to do
an investigation off the blockchain to
know if the thing that's on the
blockchain is actually working or not
there's been a lot of talk about minting
nfts related to real-world goods
creating an nft related to a house to
track who buys and sells the house
creating nft related to a car related to
the car itself but what happens when
something happens in the real world that
isn't reflected on the blockchain what
happens if the house burns down what
happens if the car gets stolen
rectifying real world events with things
on the blockchain is no easy task and is
inherently off-chain and there are other
unintended consequences along with this
as well for example alfa romeo just said
that they're going to start offering
nfts related to their cars and when you
take your alfa romeo car into being
serviced with alfa romeo there will be a
history on the blockchain that shows
that your car was serviced at such and
such a time in such in such a way and
that follows with the car but one of the
problems is what happens if you take
your car to a non-authorized dealer that
information won't make it onto the alfa
romeo blockchain it's one way that alfa
romeo might force you to use their
walled garden it'd be like drm for a car
you'd never be able to take your car to
any other service place now i am not a
computer programmer these might be
technical problems that will be fixed
over time already we're seeing
intermediaries like open c interpret the
data on blockchain and solve some of the
issues when it comes to
falsely minted nfts but if that's the
case and we need these intermediaries
that are off-chain
it raises the question
why would we want web 3 in fact we can
do all of this stuff legally
using traditional websites and
traditional legal mechanisms often the
web 3 part of it just makes things worse
which takes us to the third category of
problems with nfts which i've called
innovation so mundane that no one should
care and the issue here is that there
are probably plenty of marginal benefits
that nfts bring to the table for a wide
variety of industries they're just not
huge wins that are going to create an
enormous amount of wealth for the people
with vested interests it's pretty clear
that collectible jpegs are pretty dumb
and that this is a speculative bubble
with untold numbers of non-arm-length
transactions wash sales and sock puppets
it's pretty clear at this point that at
least this first generation of nfts are
creating a speculative bubble that is
probably going to burst pretty violently
collectible jpegs and other collectible
digital pieces of artwork it's probably
not going to last it's pretty dumb and i
think people will probably get bored
with it it's also filled with all kinds
of non-arm length transactions wash
sales and sock puppets that are propping
up the prices and just waiting for
another person to come around and buy
the thing that probably isn't worth the
sales price
but that being said there are probably
lots of other uses that are more
promising fractionalized revenue streams
access to unique membership style
opportunities proving certain kinds of
provenance and raising equity but the
thing is those
uses of nfts are genuine but they're
really just marginal improvements on
current technology if they are indeed
improvements at all and nfc acolytes are
claiming nfts are a grand slam but it's
probably more like a simple walk-on
single these improvements in technology
are probably useful but they're also
extremely mundane the technology at use
here probably will form some of the
unseen backbone of certain transactions
but it just simply won't be get rich
quick schemes it seems likely that the
huge market for nft's collectibles will
probably crash at some point and when
the bubble around jpegs dies out what
will be left is probably a technology
that
makes marginal improvements it's going
to create a few millionaires maybe even
billionaires who find
novel and practical uses for this
technology but it's not going to create
overnight millionaires for everyone that
wants to mint some low value nft going
forward and the reason that that is a
problem for nfts is that there are many
many people who have staked their entire
reputations as well as their entire
finances on the proposition that nfts
have created a completely new industry
and that it can create overnight
millionaires in anyone and when people
realize that that's not the case well
the entire industry may evaporate
overnight faster than beanie babies now
of course nfts are heralded as this
revolution in creator economics as a way
for artists to actually pay what they're
worth but people don't realize that
there's real liability in that nfts
could be incredibly dangerous if not
outright terrible for creators i go into
great detail based on my experience as a
lawyer but also my experience as a
creator myself let's just say there's a
reason i haven't minted any nfts myself
now what if i told you that you could
watch another legal eagle video but this
time it's on why nfts could be dangerous
and bad for creators well this
full-length companion video does exist
and it is exclusively on nebula because
sadly if i put it on youtube it would
probably get demonetized and there's no
way you'd ever see it but nebula is
different as you've probably heard by
now nebula is home to tons of exclusive
ad-free content like my first
full-length documentary bad law words
good a long-form interview with mark
rober exclusive videos on legal rights
you should definitely use and anti-slap
laws in kyle rittenhouse plus tons more
and all this exclusive content is only
on nebula which you can get for free
with curiosity stream of course the
reason why all these videos are only
available on nebula is because they just
wouldn't work here on youtube they'd
never be viewed because of the way that
the site works but on the other hand
nebula is a different platform with no
algorithm and without any ads because
nebula is a place where we can
experiment with content put things on
there that we couldn't put on youtube
nebula is a platform for great and
unique content made by independent
educational creators that you probably
already know like tom scott thomasfrank
and thomasflight as well as lots of
other people not named tom like half as
interesting marquez brownlee real life
lore wendover productions mike boyd
minute earth neo real engineering
knowing better and so many others
there's tons of exclusive content
released multiple times every day and
nebula is creator owned and operated and
we've been developing like crazy nebula
now has apps for ios android apple tv
roku fire tv and android tv and we're
thrilled to be partnering with curiosity
stream because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries and long-form
educational content on the internet they
even have an entire section devoted to
unsolved mysteries and crimes so if you
like my videos you'll love the stuff on
curiositystream and the best way to get
access to nebula and all this incredible
content is definitely through the
amazing curiosity stream nebula bundle
with its current sales price of less
than 15 for the entire year which gives
you access to both sites and to be clear
that nebula subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in streaming anywhere and
you get two great streaming sites with
content you'll actually watch and enjoy
and what's more signing up will actually
help countless independent educational
creators beyond just legal eagle so sign
up right now by clicking on the button
that's on screen right now which will
take you directly to curiositystream.com
legaleagle to sign up or you can click
on the link that's down below in the
description it's a great way to support
educational content and get tons of
exclusive content that you'll love so go
watch it right now or you can click on
this playlist over here with all my
other real law reviews so click on one
of these links or i'll see you in court